what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I drink
coffee and give you my thoughts and
updates for the day before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos also if my trainer Michael is
watching this um
no I didn't order Starbucks today
like you told me not to anymore
anyways
um so today
this is what we're going to be talking
about we're gonna be talking about my
banishment off of Instagram
so yesterday I opened my phone
and
my friend Chyna was here to film
something with Andy and he was here
early and I walk in and I look down and
I say gas
and
I looked down
and it said you have been banned now
people ask me what the original message
said
and I can't remember and I didn't
screenshot so I don't know the actual
reason why but I have an idea of why
some
that
yeah I I have an idea so
um I submitted something that said I
appealed it but I just I have a feeling
after this I'm not getting it back so
how did I get banished
um so I've had multiple warnings on that
account I used to get 10 shorts sent to
me a day and I would just like
blind post them
um so a long story short my Instagram
was very messy had a bunch of reels and
shorts on it
um and
I think I was already demonetized
and
I'm pretty sure
I don't know that like
I'm pretty sure I had some warnings but
this is what I'm pretty sure knocked me
off of the app so
I'm my story I I do kill it on the the
Instagram story so very entertaining if
I had an Instagram I'd tell you to
follow
so
there was a girl that called me ugly and
she was insinuating something with my
appearance it was a bit rude and so
I just asked a simple question
now she happened to be a whale
I didn't go out I didn't make her a will
I didn't go out to set out to make her
well but if I had to describe her
I would say it's whale season she's
wailing so I said I I shared it and I
said who would you rather smash me or
her
and again she called me ugly first she
started it and then she responded was
like you're so insecure that you have to
compare to me dead and I'm like you
started it you called me ugly I forgot
what she put so I shared her second
story and I just put a whale Emoji I
just put a whale Emoji whales are
beautiful majestic creatures
they're beautiful majestic creatures and
I'm the bad guy
I'm the bad now
according to Instagram I get I am
according to Instagram I am I don't
think she got banned
so
why am I banished for comparing you to a
beautiful Majestic creature
um anyways
it was unfortunate because I really did
like my Instagram but I don't really
I I'm more upset because
um recruiting for the show
um I had a lot of people that the only
way I contacted them was through
Instagram but you know honestly I was
thinking that my Instagram's a lot of
work and then I might want to hand it
over to management so if I have to make
a new Instagram
I'll just let my management take it over
they didn't tell me if anyone
anyone DMS me that I need to know about
I was like this would just be easier I
don't have to deal with it at all
um and I was thinking that my Instagram
would be better if I didn't have so many
reels I don't know so maybe it's a good
thing I'm not too pressed and it's a
test everyone says women can't survive
without Instagram but it's day one and
I'm doing okay I'm doing fine
my dad says he says
Hannah why do you care he'll be like
why do you respond to these girls and
I'm like Dad
I'm not offended I don't care I think
it's funny
I genuinely I just think it's funny and
my dad said it wasn't worth your
Instagram
and I'm like Dad kind of like honestly
if I if I lose my Instagram over this
I'm not even pressed I'm not even
pressed
okay guys
well what should I make if I get a new
Instagram what should I make the handle
be let me know in the comments
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel
and tell Instagram to give me my page
back or don't you know I don't really
care
anyways talk to you later bye